welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the queen of sex education
Ella Lackey how are you I am great Lori
oh I'm spelling Gloria you're back I'm
back blessed be we're back in business
ladies back in our lives because she's
very like outspoken she wants have a
waist to be her doesn't shake well what
I did was before I came and met you
today yeah I dug up the interview we did
the first time and I read it and you
said this thing which I laughed which is
the one thing I want to change about sex
education in school is this actually
fundamentally about pleasure we'll often
taught in school that sex is just a
reproduction and women are baby-making
machines am I wrong
she is not wrong still completely agree
with past me well done yes
the way we're going to bring down the
patriarchal system is with sex education
now I wondered what your opinion was on
that comment and how that's changed over
the last year not even not just female
pledge we're not talking about gay sex
we're not we're not teaching people how
to protect themselves or sleep and
without it being a reproduction thing
yeah you're gonna get pregnant
yeah if you don't use a condom yeah I
mean it's so much more layered than that
and doesn't have to be all scary and
mysterious like a Hollywood set we're
all here because of it I know it's
really cute like it's redundant in a way
because we say it so much but we all
here because of sex yeah just get over
it and talk about it
and I know it's not comfortable for
everyone and I know there's a million
like you know religion and and tradition
and and you know shyness you know there
are so many things that come and kind of
hinder that discussion from kind of that
discussion so I think that yeah I so
really is it is a tool it can be a tool
and I still completely agree yeah I love
that okay this show breaks so many
different taboos in so many different
ways when you were growing up what to
boo this show breaks with a helped you
the most just the tip the taboo of women
of girls being horny
yeah I'm wanting to have sex and it not
being like all she's a freaking him
folks
it's like she just wants time they tell
me like it's how it's like dirty and I'm
not generalizing I'm talking about my
experience and I'm not talking about
everyone but the boys at my school were
taught we're actively talking about porn
and like when King and it was fine and I
just got so emember going red in the
face being like oh my god Ali talked so
embarrassing when obviously like
everyone's doing it it's just that there
is such a there's like this weight on
girls it's like you can upload the
mileage I mean because it's dirty and
now I feel like everyone's talking about
it it's really cool and I'm like yeah
masturbation for the next you get that
other teacher sorry I need to stop just
stop
what's your own journey with your having
like representing your inner voice and
making sure your inner voice is heard
what's how's that change is you've gone
through your life do you think it's
changed quite drastically I feel like
again this this job specifically has
been quite a catalyst it has been quite
a turning point anyway for me because
when I look back on my life I think that
that if the inner voice being heard or
like speaking up for myself has come
from other people believing in me and
giving me a leg up so to speak and kind
of like ensuring that I'm confident
within myself because they've shown
confidence in me so that's a way that's
always been a really big help for me and
has boosted me so I rely or have relied
quite heavily on other people in the
past and now because of this job and
because I'm sort of figuring out the
things on my own
I've become more sort of independent and
know when to speak up for myself which
is cool and quite empowering
it's a moment you can remember sitting
there thinking SH lobes say this shall I
not shall I say this shall I not and
you've done it and you were proud of
proud of yourself
it would have been yea just simple
things even around the table with my
brothers or like when my brothers were
at an age where they loved to poke me
and just say all the wrong things you
have to be like you need I'm gonna
educate you sit down and listen to what
I have to say just like little things I
like even at home you kind of you find
strengthened in in those moments and
when you can speak up for yourself and
speak up for what you believe in
whatever that is whatever that is gonna
be something tiny but I think that you
kind of build up your confidence
it's overtime and it doesn't come
straightaway it's not an easy thing do
you know I mean I'm not supposed to just
have it all there it takes time because
say these characters on this amazing
journey of self-discovery yeah and they
start to tap into parts themselves that
they didn't really tap into before and
they become better people they've become
more well form to have better
understandings of themselves
what's your own journey been like with
self-discovery it's it's taken time you
know I'm only 23 I mean it's not like
you don't just get a degree and you
don't you're doing a degree in
self-discovery in your boom you're off
I'm very lucky to be surrounded by
people who have my best interests at
heart and who and vice versa you know
people I really care about who kind of I
think you need to surround yourself with
people who give off a good energy and
who don't feed off the aged remains so I
think that when once you learn that what
you don't have to filter out those nasty
people you become stronger and you and
you know what makes you tick and what
works for you and that's not being
selfish in a negative way that's just
looking out for yourself it's quite
philosophical especially with this job
which can which is still so new to me
and still kind of sometimes can be a bit
like overwhelming and surreal I think
it's really important to have a really
simple life and like the happiest time
is when I'm in my little flat and with
my music and my plants and cooking or
whatever whatever it is the really
simple thing is I think that's when I
feel kind of leveled and balanced
because I guess like I met you a year
ago let's just thinking about this yeah
I met you a year ago where literally you
you guys want Google Bowl I'll Google
evolve and you would go already go on
this journey you didn't know where it
was gonna end up and everyone was hyping
it up and and it came out in January and
then your life lit she just went like
that overnight how did you deal with
that change cuz I guess it was such a
shock in so many ways as well I still
don't think I have the distance from it
I feel like it's moving a bit well windy
because it's such a solid group the
actors are mean and because we were so
well looked after by the crew and
production everything I feel like the
found eight hour foundation is really
solid and good and healthy and so that's
been our starting
pointless show has been our starting
point so we're kind of growing up
together and that has enabled us to stay
grounded and level-headed because we
know we're all in this together
what's this taught you this job about
sisterhood because there's such a strong
system that goes on on this show yes
wasn't talking about that and the power
of girl yeah I mean how important it is
I feel like there's there are it's not a
new thing but I feel like certainly this
generation this and shows and the plays
and the things that are coming out of
our generation is so brilliant and like
exciting and it feels that there's a
real movement happening and I know
everyone always talks about it but it is
it's really happening and there's
something it's like it hasn't happened
before or just like what they call this
absurd wait with feminism feminism is a
new thing yeah it's just that people are
like oh yeah common sense so it's just
like it's just people are like waking up
because there's no excuse not to anymore
because all this information is at our
fingertips so you your duty is to be
curious and to educate yourself on
things like feminism and again and
whatever and just and to work together
because it's the world's pretty shaped
not to burst anyone's bubble a narrative
art for your character is she's seen as
an outsider yeah in so many ways and
there's this whole battle at that school
with popularity what is your own
relationship been like with popularity
and if you've ever felt like an outsider
how have you dealt with it so at school
I wasn't popular I think I wanted to be
part of like the cool kids whoever they
were but there was no I was lucky to be
in quite a small school that was kind of
quite relatively relaxed so there was no
there was no real
peaky business going on but I was I was
always a little bit of an outsider just
because I just I just didn't really want
to get involved in drama and stuff and
they really didn't interest me and so um
I just read a lot of books and studied
and but they didn't make me a weirdo
necessarily I just was I just selected
carefully I think I'm happy you keep on
saying it I will you worry I will
thank you